your mom is probably your biggest fan is
that safe to say yes okay and
does she ever had being your mom has she
ever
had a problem with anything you've done
your character on orange is the new
black has she ever had a problem with
this scene or it's because
it felt like it was over the line for
her um you know there have been a couple
i mean the things that i've been
surprised because she liked like the
most violent scene from season one which
i was very i'm surprised my family's
from nigeria and she's this little you
know conservative woman and the most
violent scene in season one which she
was into but then scenes that she wasn't
really
comfortable with was there was a scene
where i peed on the floor
and um
yeah literally
and you know she just would like
everyone i remember seeing that scene i
was like mom you know what you think
she's just like
just that kind of face just like an eye
roll kind of like okay and i was like
all right i mean but you did like the
beating up scene but okay whatever right
um and it was i was nervous when i did
that scene initially because one i was
peeing on floor two i was peeing on the
floor in front of jodie foster who
directed that episode
which was a journey in itself i was like
i'm peeing on the floor
in front of jody foster okay
this is but it was amazing the dream we
all had
exactly
it happened it finally happened i made
it you know like yeah you uh you you
this is very cool you
introduced your mother
to president obama the first lady yeah
tell us about that
that was
crazy eyes like i just literally could
not believe it i was we went to the
white house they were in the same
marathon
yeah i never believed it exactly um yeah
we were when we went to the white house
we got to go and we had dinner they were
kind enough to invite us over and have
us for um us uh dinner that summer and
we just you know we're sitting across
from the president the first lady of the
united states
and i'm thinking my mom is who is a huge
talker is going to be gabby gabby gabby
talking and i'm going to have to you
know nudge her at some point to be like
mom stop like let the president run the
world and um instead you know
when he introduces himself he's like
hello nice to meet you you know how are
you doing i was like very well mr
president thank you and he's like who's
this i was like this is my mom you know
she's come with me and he's like go i'd
love to meet your mom and i'm ready to
stop if this conversation is going to go
on for 20 minutes right and all my mom
had to say the president was like mrs
aduba how are you and she was like fine
and didn't have anything else
not the day was great i'm so happy to be
here you should have pretended to take a
cell phone yeah
we have a picture that i just want to
show the picture this is your mom
talking to yeah the first lady is she
happy in that moment
he is well by that time right by that
time my mom was now she's a gift yapping
away now she's really cool she's really
gone oh she's going full steam she's
telling them everybody from like how
much she knits everything she's telling
them everything but that was
unbelievable time that was pretty
special